ce qu'ils ont ce qui est en jeu autour
du pouvoir des gaffes à c'est bien plus
qu'un pouvoir économique une capacité à
court terme
extraire de l'argent des consommateurs
c'est prendre des positions dominantes
sur le temps très long sur le temps très
long des décennies peut-être c'est un
type de changement de civilisation si
vous du changement de logique
c'est une véritable fusion de
l'économique et du politique
alors il ya des chercheurs sur les
médias qui parlent de gouvernementalité
algorithmique pour ça pour dire quoi
pour dire que ce que font les gars fin
aux fonds sont en train d'organiser une
prévision de nos comportements et une
capacité à prévoir de nos comportements
qui implique une capacité à les guider
on passe très rapidement de la logique
de prévisions à la logique de de guidage
ça c'est le premier problème est le
deuxième problème c'est qu'évidemment
cette position de notre leur propre
permet ensuite un d'extraire une des
richesses très importante mois le point
sur lequel je je je souhaiterais mettre
l'accent c'est le fait que plus ces
entreprises sont grandes plus elles sont
efficaces plus elles ont des données
plus elles sont susceptibles de rendre
des services importants le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que ses services elle
les rendent de manière biaisée à leur
propre profit sans prendre en compte les
critères qui devraient être ceux de nos
besoins de développement aujourd'hui et
donc la politique publique et le débat
public devrait s'orienter sur la
régulation l'encadrement voir dans la
mesure du possible des formes de
socialisation évidemment ça semble
utopique aujourd'hui d'imaginer un
service public de la recherche numérique
mais c'est dans cette direction là qu'il
s'agit de penser parce que l'enjeu n'est
certainement pas de restaurer de la
concurrence et je voudrais vous donner
un seul exemple aujourd'hui la
commission européenne demande à ce que
sur les appareils android de la
concurrence soient mises en oeuvre pour
décider quel va être le moteur de
recherche qui va être sur les téléphones
la logique c'est que les différentes
entreprises vont aller aux enchères vais
avoir un système d'enchères pour avoir
le droit de d'installer son moteur de
recherche sur un sur un téléphone la
conséquence de ça c'est quoi c'est que
le moteur de recherche qui paiera le
plus cher sera celui qui exigera aura le
plus besoin de faire des profits avec
nos données et donc va surexploités
notre notre usage de ce moteur de
recherche pour pouvoir rentabiliser son
investissement
donc voyez bien que reste de la
concurrence augmenter la concurrence
finalement contribué à accroître encore
la logique marchande à socialiser
l'utilisation de nos données
[Musique]